I know this sounds real dumb, but Polar Bears
are bears right? So why don't they hibernate
in the winter?
[MUSIC]
Howdy kids, Trace here with the bear necessities
for DNews! Polar bears live in the Arctic
Circle, which might cause you to assume it's
the long days which keep these fuzzy ursas
from enjoying a long winter's nap, but science
believes otherwise. Hibernation is a strange
business, it's not the same as sleeping. Science
is still figuring out how to properly define
hibernation -- as all animals do it a little
differently.
Hibernation is a way to conserve energy during
the months of the year when food for some
animals grows scarce. Bears, groundhogs and
chipmunks jump to mind first, but some fish,
reptiles, birds and bats also experience it
in some way. During hibernation, breathing
and heart rate slow, metabolism plummets and
body temperature follows that trend too.
It's sort of like a natural state of suspended
animation! Hibernating animals are going through
physiological changes, whereas sleeping animals
are maintaining normal physiology, but changing
their mental state. It's very difficult to
wake up a hibernating animal, and doing so
takes SO much energy it wouldn't go back under
again. Seriously, the arctic ground squirrel's
body temperature gets so low, the neurons
of its brain are incapable of firing. Bears
aren't "true hibernators," because they don't
shut down like that -- but they don't need
food or water all winter, which is a mark
of hibernation as well. And they don't poop
or pee. Nope. Not even once.
Polar bears don't hibernate, but the females
CAN go 240 days without food. During this
time, they commonly lose around 1.7 pounds
per day (0.77 kg) and birth cubs. They escape
the harsh winter by "denning" or building
a hollow in the snow. Meanwhile the males
hunt or stalk seals and other prey, in what's
called "walking hibernation," meaning their
body temperature remains normal but their
metabolic rate slows down.
A study in Genome Biology and Evolution compared
the genetic code of hibernating brown and
black bears to that of the non-hibernating
polar bears to find out how they can do that
without curling up to sleep. Within the DNA,
researchers discovered polar bears have genes
which ramp up nitric oxide production. Nitric
oxide tells the polar bear's body to stop
breaking down fat into energy, and instead
convert it directly to heat in a process called
adaptive or non-shivering thermogenesis. Basically,
polar bears have a thermostat to keep them
warm and help conserve energy in response
to their current diet or environment.
For the record, panda bears, sun bears, sloth
bears of Asia and spectacled bears of South
America also do not hibernate -- mainly, like
with the polar bear -- because there's no
season lack of food. Sorry brown and black
bears... Go sleep it off.
What's your favorite bear? Polar? Panda? Bear-o-dactyl?!
Subscribe, and leave a comment below and thanks
for watching DNews everyone!